hi this is presh talker
in this video i'm going to illustrate an
amazing fact from geometry
known as pascal's theorem or the
hexagramma mysticum
we'll get right to the examples
we'll start out by drawing two different
lines
and on each line we'll pick three points
a b c
and on the other line a prime b prime
and c prime
we're going to connect some of these
points together
to get our result
so we'll start out by connecting a with
b prime
and correspondingly
b with a prime
you'll notice that these two lines
have a point of intersection
and we'll mark that with the green dot
we're going to draw two more pairs of
lines so we'll draw
ac prime
and correspondingly c a prime
and you'll notice that these two lines
also have a point of intersection
we'll mark that with the green dot
finally we'll draw b c prime
and cb prime
and once again these two lines have a
point of intersection
which we'll mark with the green dot
so here's the result here's pascal's
theorem it's at these three points
these three green dots will always lie
on a line they will always be on the
same line
and to illustrate this
uh it will even be true even if i try
and squish this figure up
you'll see that these three points are
always on a line
and i'll try and deform it again
these three points remain on a line
and we'll return back these three points
are always on the same line
and this will be true no matter where
you pick the points
for the two different lines
the story gets even more interesting
that we can do this with other shapes
so we'll start out with the circle
and we'll pick six different points
and we'll connect exactly the same pairs
of lines that we did before
so we end up with a set of three points
and you'll very easily see that these
are on the same line
and while i started out with the circle
this will be true even if we have an
ellipse
and no matter what the shape of the
ellipse is
these three points
will always be on a line
let's get more daring
let's start out that
will have an ellipse but this time we're
not going to put abc all next to each
other we'll mix it up
so now when we connect the lines
it looks like
we don't have any intersections
we just have a hexagon which is inside
of an ellipse
so what we need to do
is we actually need to extend our lines
beyond the shape so we'll extend a b
prime
and b a prime until they do intersect at
a point
and we'll continue
so that we keep extending the opposite
pairs of lines until they intersect
and now we have three points which we've
denoted with green dots and lo and
behold
these actually are on the same line
and this again will be true
pretty much however you draw the shape
and we'll try and
form it you'll see that
this is always these three points are
always on the same line
let's get a little creative we'll take a
parabola we'll draw six different points
and we'll connect the same lines that
we've been connecting
once again we found that the three
points of intersection
are going to be on the same line
if you really want to be daring our
final example will be with the hyperbola
we'll pick
six different points and connect
the uh relevant pairs of lines
and almost like magic these three three
green dots are on the same line
the reason this happens it's known as
pascal's theorem
which is from any six points on a conic
section
when you draw out the lines a b prime b
prime a
a c prime c prime a and b c prime c
prime b
as long as those you know none of those
pairs of lines are parallel as long as
they're non-parallel pairs of lines
the points of intersections of those
lines those three points will be
collinear
and so that's why it always worked when
we had a hyperbola
parabola ellipse or circle
and to go back to the first example we
started out with two pairs of lines
the reason that works is pappas theorem
i provided some links in the description
which will get you to more details of
the math and proof of why it works
i hope you enjoyed this video
please subscribe to my channel
you can catch me on my blog buying your
decisions on twitter at preshtalwalker
or again my ebooks and amazon